all right what's shaking what can i do
for you bro how's it going
good good so you uh so you're the title
of the video what uh high value men or
sorry
uh what high value women want in men or
something like that so i have a question
is
so there are some how you value men and
women obviously desire them
so why is it that some of them when they
desire them
they end up getting pissed off that
their alpha or
red pill and these men are expressing it
to them and they actually
act surprised that you know these men
are like this is when
in reality this is what they want if
that makes sense yeah yeah
now i know what you're saying so what
you're basically saying if i can
paraphrase is
they find the guy that they like or
sorry they find the guy that they're
highly attracted
to and they love but what they end up
doing is they
dislike the personality that created the
alpha that they
want to bang yeah that's right yeah so
that's pretty common and it's just a
function of the way society is today
um aaron cleary wrote a good book so
shout out to my friend aaron
called the book of numbers it's it's
it's more of a booklet it's not very
long to read so i mean you can get
through it in an afternoon very very
quickly but
he basically breaks down the return on
investment on
um dating and investing your time money
and resources in women and
he basically came to the same conclusion
that i did which was
uh chase excellence not women his number
breaks it down to a specific number and
it's a very
very low percentage of women that are
like datable marriageable type of
material for average guys out there let
alone the high value guys so i mean like
you got to understand
there's some top shelf guys out there
that make seven eight figures
um and have acquired a vast amount of
wealth that will scoop up these women
before the average guy can't
yeah that makes sense so i mean like
you're going to run into that with
chicks you know there's going to be the
woke squad the oppression olympic squad
you know and all that comes from like
the
hardcore left-leaning agenda you know
that really
you know tries to vilify men and
masculinity
and the weird thing is like you know
like experiences women are strongly
attracted to
men that have strong masculine virtues
and cues but they don't like it when
these guys set up boundaries or they're
like red pilled or something like that i
don't wanna getting red pill he's gonna
he's gonna do this or he's gonna cheat
on me that's like
like chill like chill okay like just
like just toe the line okay that's all
you have to do
so the yeah that's a good point now the
other thing too i noticed is that
i think like when i became more red pill
aware is
some of the women that i knew and you
know what it's whatever i could care
less but i noticed
you mentioned that i think in a few
videos where yeah they changed their
attitude because now you've discovered
the truth of
of their nature so i guess what i'm
trying to figure out is
why is it that they don't want to know
the truth then why don't they want us to
know
women see this is where guys go
deeply wrong is when we try to explain
red pill concepts to women they don't
want it
they don't want to hear it they're going
to pretend like they want to hear like
there's a lot of women that watch my
show
um about five to ten percent of my
audience actually women so
almost like one in ten now are chicks
watches but they're watching as a fly on
the wall
right so they really could care less
well they want to hear what the men are
talking about
okay yeah like they're they're trying to
learn for themselves for the betterment
of themselves so
there's a you know there's a part of
that that you gotta admire to some
degree
but at the end of the day like are they
really gonna do the work like are they
actually gonna act on it no so
women just want guys to get it generally
speaking you know if i can distill it
down anything you don't want to explain
these things to
to them you don't you shouldn't have to
explain these things to them they just
want to be with a guy that they can look
up to
that they see as a giant that is their
best option
you know and they're very happy with
that's all that they want and
if that's gonna come with you know him
you know looking at some chick with
giant boobs when she walks in front of
him
she's gonna have to suck it up right or
she's gonna open her mouth
or she's gonna open up her mouth and
he's going to be like i don't care
you know because he's red pill i don't
care well
all you want but that's yeah i love the
hypocrisy not too
because it's like well you know if if uh
if she looks at
you know a decent looking man you know
and if he
if he comments on it then there's
pointing and sputtering going on but you
know
i don't know i just find it hit you know
hypocritical
hey listen there's there's nothing fair
about anything for dudes so just so just
get over like
you know the concept of fairness you
know and hypocrisy and all like women
are just women
okay like you know solipsism hypergamy
it's not a bug of who they are it's just
the future
yeah right so you just accept them you
know for what they are
you can love them for what they are it's
all good in the hood you don't have to
worry about anything else and just don't
let them get under your skin like you
don't
like one of the things that comes up
over and over again is when guys argue
with women's like don't argue with women
like stop
wasting your breath yeah just walk away
yeah right
remove your attentional walk away anyway
you get the point though right
yeah that makes perfect sense you'll be
all right okay man
appreciate it thanks a lot thanks
you